تقع [موسيقى]
بين الجبال المغطاة بالثلوج
في أعماق مقاطعة كوان في كوريا الجنوبية
واحدة من أكثر جنون المنتجعات حرارة في
البلاد ونعني حرفيًا أن الأقمار
تحتاج أيضًا إلى الظهيرة في حساب جونكا
للفيديو
[الموسيقى]
لعب الفحم دورًا مهمًا
يعود تاريخ استخدامه في الثقافة الكورية إلى أكثر من
2600 عام لتدفئة المنازل لطهي الطعام
ودرء الطاقة السيئة ،
لذلك فاز جانغ ووالده بالفحم
من أوكلاند الفريد من نوعه في هذه
المنطقة ، إنها عملية شاقة
تبدأ وتنتهي بأفران أو
أفران عملاقة  طالب أنطونيو الزبادي التركي في
كوماسي بفتح نافذة عند 20 انتصارًا ،
إريك توكاجي لافينيا كامارا أنت
ميزو سو كاميون دي فو كوشير دي
سوليل تشيكو ليس في هذا الحريم كل
قمر جديد محرج booga boosha Peter
Sam Viktor مفتول العضلات ناوكو على
الكاميرا عسلي مفتوح جيمي هوفا في a
ملف تعريف الارتباط المصغر ، تعمل الأفران
كساونا كورية تقليدية ، وهو
علاج كان يحدث لمئات
السنين
يدفع العملاء رسومًا رمزية لقضاء بعض الوقت
أتعرق من سمومهم في الغرف الساخنة
بنفسه في تركيا الجماعة تعرفني أندرو
الساحر الشاب غير المنطقي الذي كان
مطيعًا والذي كان يتعين على إيطاليا
مقابلتك قبله كنت
شريرًا ، الكونغو ساخرة تخبرك
أنها فاسقة توني على الإطلاق أنا قلعة
النزعة الإنسانية أموال صادقة ، يحسب المتبرعين
الذين أخطأوا ببساطة في هذا وسيظل عامل
جذب وطني لذلك ليس لدى Jung Hwan
أي خطط لإبطاء العمل العائلي
أريد مقابلة المحيط وأتمنى
لي في المجموع حتى جون ريتشموند أو رؤية
موافقة عالمية على نظام الدفع
موعد مع اليقظة التي تعرف أن
الآخرين تحب بعض الدجاج و
Paramus جيد لك
[موسيقى]